Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life, for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I am Link.
This week, at the
Roundtable of Dim Lighting,
I'm giving you your tit for tat.
The tit was your trip to Key West,
Yeah.
And it was a lot of tits.
Yeah, you're not going-
Gotta give me some tats, man
to have nearly as many as me.
If you saw as many tits in Big Sur,
as I saw in Key West, then,
I don't know what festival that was.
Well, let me tell you I did,
but they were all on the same woman.
Just different instances.
Ah, okay.
I see where you're going with that.
So I will say, there is a little,
there's going to be some
conversation about sex,
in this-
Seems to be something we're doing lately.
Once we, you know, we
busted that hatch open.
Yeah.
And now we're just
crawling around out of it,
again and again.
But you know, I feel free to,
I think it's going to
come up in conversation-
Yeah, okay.
When telling you about my
trip to Big Sur, with Christy,
at the same time that
you were in Key West,
I was doing that.
It was just the two of us.
Shorter trip, didn't
have to get on a plane,
totally different vibe,
kind of like the different
vibes in what we're wearing,
which I will get to what I'm
wearing, in a little bit,
and also get to what you're wearing.
But yeah, I'm going to, I'm
going to talk about that.
And then I think, towards
the end of this conversation,
by way of recommendation,
I'm going to talk about
sex in a different way,
that's not related to my own experience,
Oh?
But some things
that I've learned, through
a series that I watched,
that I just, I want to talk to you about,
so I'm going to save some time for that.
So just kind of a, a side A and a side B,
to this conversation, that
I envisioned happening.
But that's a little bit of a warning,
if you've had enough of sex
talk, from Rhett and Link-
Who has?
Just,
Who would say that?
Go to something else,
or once we start getting
into that, you can skip...
I have a little sex update,
I guess you could call it,
that I have to get into.
well, okay. Go right for it now.
Like a errors and omissions situation.
Okay, from the last episode?
I teased last week's episode,
about getting shot with a wiener gun.
From a golf cart, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I never told the story,
'cause there's no story,
It was just, I was
walking down the street,
and there was a woman with
a giant penis water gun-
Now when you say giant.
and it was just shooting...
You talking about, it was like a shotgun?
No, I'm saying it was-
Like a wiener.
I'm saying, when I say giant, I mean,
giant as if it were an actual penis,
it would be like, "That's a big penis",
but not like a super soaker,
which would be like, "no
one's got that penis",
and if they do, they're in
a record book somewhere,
it's just more like-
That's a special record book
That's a big penis, but it's not,
it's just a, it's a water gun.
I don't think Guinness
is in the business of measuring peni.
Not anymore. Yeah.
Sadly.
But they, she squirted me.
She squirted everyone.
I mean, she was just having
the time of her life.
Was it water?
Yeah.
I mean, it didn't, It
didn't go in my mouth,
but it didn't smell weird.
It went in your nose.
It just went on my face and like, chest.
Oh wow.
That's a bold move.
Yeah. Yeah, she got me.
Hey, you can get away on
that golf cart though,
Yeah, yeah.
Another advantage.
I could've have never caught up with her.
I don't know what I would've
done, grabbed her gun?
I had made plans to go to Big Sur,
and then they were
eradicated by the pandemic.
So for our 20 year wedding anniversary,
which in 2020, is when
we were going to go.
I had it booked,
I had to cancel,
so I ended up going
back to that same place.
But since then, you've been,
and then I heard about the place,
because Stevie recommended it,
Mm-hm.
And I started looking into it.
It's called Glenoaks.
They took a motor home,
not a motor home, a motor lodge?
That's been in Big Sur for a long time,
and they revamped that.
But you can't even really see that,
I never actually saw that part of it,
and then they also have cabins.
Like individual or like,
two cabins put together.
And so you can rent out one of those.
This is very much a glamping experience,
It's like the best of both worlds,
I was very much looking forward to it.
By the time I re booked,
I didn't get the cabin that I wanted.
When you're driving up through Big Sur,
there's basically just Highway One.
There's nothing, man.
And you're going, you're going up there,
And it's, I mean,
there's so many pictures,
so many screensavers of Big Sur,
that you didn't even know.
And there's the Bixby Bridge,
which was built in 1936,
this huge, beautiful, arching,
under arched bridge,
that when you drive across it,
you might not appreciate
how amazing it is,
until you look back,
it's right on the coast.
It's that one, if you watched,
is it Big Little Lies?
Is in the intro.
I haven't watched that,
Christy watched that without me.
It's good.
It's good, especially the bridge part.
Oh really?
Every episode.
She only told me about the wiener part.
There was like, there was a-
Sarsgaard.
There was an erect wiener, walking around.
I think it was probably a prosthetic.
I don't think,
I think that's how they do it these days.
So you're when you're driving up,
you're right on the coast,
and so much of the coast is just these,
I know you went,
and I know you talked
about it on Ear Biscuits,
and I don't want to rehash everything,
but it just bears
repeating, how beautiful-
Maybe the most beautiful place on Earth.
Central coast of California.
I've never been to the Northern
coast of California, yet.
And I kind of thought I
was in Northern California,
until I looked at the map.
There's a lot of California,
Very much central.
You know, there's a whole
part of North, of California,
the Lost Coast where,
the train is too crazy,
they couldn't even get
a road to hug the coast,
that you can get there by certain roads.
Yeah. Our friend Nick went up there.
I gotta get up there.
That whole, I mean, there's, I mean,
that's a completely different world,
hardly any people up there.
So when you're going, I mean, you're,
you're right on the edge of these cliffs,
and you can look down,
and just see the waves crashing
against the rugged
coastline of California.
There's a few places,
where it turns into very rugged beaches,
and there's a handful of state parks,
along, in the Big Sur area.
But when you really drive to Glenoaks,
and I think you went to Ventana?
I can't remember what it was called.
No, I went to the,
You can't even remember?
It was like the best
place I've ever stayed.
And I was just completely,
the post, Post Ranch.
Post Ranch.
Those are real, that's not glamping,
that's, resort stuff,
which is very cool.
And I want to do that-
But it's individual cabins, though.
Oh?
Yeah. It's not a resort.
It's just resort prices.
It's exorbitant.
But it, we stayed in a
tree house that was just,
Oh yeah, you stayed in a tree house.
It was just an individual tree house.
I do remember this now.
These cabins are on the ground.
But when you're, I really began,
I had driven through Big
Sur a couple of times,
and I began to really
appreciate the topography of,
at a certain point,
you leave the coast and you
veer in to the Redwoods,
that are all growing in there.
And there's this huge ravine, huge valley,
and you can't, you can
no longer see the ocean.
And then you're kind of going down,
there, into the bottom,
and the Big Sur river comes through there.
Is it the Carmel valley?
No, I don't.
I don't know that it has a
name, it's Big Sur, proper,
at that particular place,
where these cabins are.
On the right side of the
road, when you're going north,
was where you check in,
and the cabin that Christy
and I ended up staying in,
but the cabin I wanted and
that are the most coveted,
are the ones across the street,
and then you walk down,
to where the river is gently
flowing through there,
and there's cabins all around it,
and it's nothing but Redwood groves,
very rustic cabins.
So I want to go back,
and I'd definitely do some reconnaissance,
there's an opportunity
for you and Jessie to come with us,
maybe we can bring some other friends,
'cause there's some other
places to stay at Glenoaks,
that can accommodate more people,
that look totally isolated,
and absolutely amazing.
At the same place,
just different parts of the same place?
Yeah.
But the cabin we stayed
in was on the other,
was on the other side,
but it was still an amazing
glamping experience.
You got this king bed,
and then you've got a little kitchenette.
You've got this fireplace in the room,
that's very cute and nice and glampy.
And then they've got a
bathroom with heated floors.
Hm, oh yeah.
You got those heated tiles.
It gets cool up there, man.
Yeah, it can get really cold,
it's nice to be able to walk barefoot,
and then sit down on your throne.
And there was a two person shower,
two separate shower heads,
shower pressure and heat was very great.
They really put a lot of their attention-
Shower pressure note.
I mean, these things really matter,
when you're talking about glamping,
the difference between
camping and glamping-
I mean, shower pressure is important.
Heat, shower pressure,
and I didn't know it, but
heated floors in the bathroom.
It's not a Motel 6,
I mean, you're going to get,
I mean, they don't get hot water,
First of all, Motel 6 is going
to give you hot water too,
But you don't know about the pressure.
And you also don't know
about the mattress.
The mattress could have
been a little bit better.
The sheets could have
been a little bit better,
but I'm spoiled.
The sheets could have been better?
This is my review, we
have some sheets at home,
that are like, just
T-shirt, they're so soft.
And these have been
like Cloroxed to death,
which makes us feel good.
So Christy and I are
having this conversation,
and we're not complaining,
'cause it's like,
well, you know they're
clean, because they're-
They're hard?
They're a little hard.
They feel like they've
been bleached to death.
What I'm really trying to say is,
you've got the environment of camping,
but it's glamorous in there.
Oh yeah.
I was very much looking forward
to staying for three nights,
so that I could get two full days
of just Christy and I just hanging out,
and just being together.
Like there are trails that
you can go on, around there,
but we were like, we're
not going to do that,
this is just about us-
No hiking?
hanging out, we're not
doing the hiking thing.
Christy had some sort of,
she might've developed a reputation.
The first time she's on this podcast,
one of the first things she
says is, "I have diarrhea".
So leading up to this
trip, she had diarrhea,
but she had-
You didn't have to say it.
She had gotten it under,
well, it plays into what happened.
Okay.
So yeah, I do have to say it.
All right.
And with her permission,
but she is developing a
reputation as the Diarrhea Woman.
She had gotten it under control,
it kind of subsided, in the two
days leading up to our trip,
and then we're driving the
five and a half hour drive,
to Big Sur,
and we stop at Pismo Beach.
You remember in 2008, for
the great American road trip-
World largest clam.
we were going to just,
we were trying to make a song called,
"The World's Largest Song",
which is basically just footage of us,
in front of the world's
largest tourist trap stuff,
which we drove way out of our way,
to go to Pismo beach.
The Pez museum was also
there, though wasn't it?
That was outside of San Francisco,
Same trip.
in Burlingame,
And then matter of fact,
there's a place north of
there called Castroville,
that has the world's largest artichoke.
You remember going there?
Oh yeah, yeah.
I remember we did our
Thursday night Rhett and
Link cast, live from the RV,
with very sketchy internet,
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
from the parking lot
of the world's largest artichoke,
which is basically just a,
It's not real.
Papier mache/concrete,
artichoke edifice, on the side of a diner.
Which also the world's largest clam,
is also just a concrete thing.
Yeah.
These are not impressive.
It says "Welcome to Pismo beach".
So I'm like "Christy,
that's, I've been here".
And so then it was
lunchtime, so we stopped,
we found a highly rated place,
right on the beach, we were
able to watch the surf,
and we ate this lobster crab roll.
And then we get back in the car,
and Christy's like,
"I'm not feeling good".
Oh.
"I think some urgency is returning,"
Oh wow.
"and I need some more medicine."
So we're like going to get
some anti-diarrheal medicine,
Trip really start off with a bang.
This is great.
I mean, cause you think about,
all right, we're going
to get through this.
She was okay, but there
was like rumblings.
Right.
You know, when you're on that road trip,
and you get the rumbles,
that's a little disconcerting.
I mean, if I'm assuming that you guys are,
and you've actually talked about this,
but we're the same way,
it's like when you're on vacation,
and you're, you're married, with children-
Mm-hm.
You get to the hotel room and it's-
First thing you want to
do is take a liquid shit.
Right, exactly.
No, you want to, get it on,
Right.
You want a break in that cabin.
You want to just bend it over,
and tell that cabin to submit.
Why, where is a cabin so involved?
You got to get the ki-
Oh yeah, it's every part,
you involve every part of the cabin.
You might as well hold
onto the wall or something.
Hold on, hold on to those antlers.
There were no antlers.
I mean, we do get there, by
the time we got there, it was,
she's like texting the doctor's office,
because she had read this
thing about how raw onions-
There was a salmonella outbreak.
A salmonella outbreak?
Well, not nationwide, like 37 states.
And she was pretty convinced that
that's what was happening.
Yeah.
And so we get there and yeah,
there's no walking into the
cabin and getting it going.
Unless it's, unless it's a bathroom trip.
Hey, heated floors.
You don't want anything to
land on these heated floors,
'cause I guess it would start to cook.
Okay, God.
You don't want to hear a
sizzle, from the other room,
You know what I'm saying?
I'm sorry guys. I'm sorry.
That didn't happen.
And the floor wasn't that hot,
it was just warm, for the record.
But we finally get there. And I had,
after we left there,
and she was feeling bad,
and she's on the phone with the doctor,
and trying to troubleshoot
this salmonella stuff.
If that's what's been going on with her,
I'm like, "Grab that cold
brew out of the back,
'cause we're not going to stop
for me to have the coffee that I need,
at three o'clock in the afternoon."
And I just drank a cold,
I pulled over on the side of the road,
I drank a cold brew, while
Christy sat in the car,
and took her anti-nausea pill,
because then that was happening
on these curvy PCH roads.
The thing I didn't know about that area,
is there's nothing to stop at.
You can pull off so you
can look at scenery,
and that's the beauty of it.
So this is a little town,
"Oh, is there a restaurant here?"
No.
"Is there a place that we
can get a cup of coffee?"
Like you'll go very long
stretches with nothing.
It's pristine,
but you don't really,
you got to bring this stuff with you.
I didn't want her vomiting,
from being car sick,
as well as everything else we established.
So I gave her 20 minutes,
sitting in the car,
It's a rough road.
While I downed my cold brew.
And then a couple hours later,
by the time we get there,
I'm like, "Man, I'm feeling bad too."
I'm feeling super wired,
like I drank way too much cold brew,
and I felt absolutely horrible,
like my head was spinning,
I hadn't eaten anything.
I was also a little car sick,
she was sick.
You guys aren't even
gonna be able to make it.
This is a great start to our Big Sur trip.
You specialize in good
starts to trips, though.
I'm telling you, man.
Yeah,
The doctor called in,
just for, out of safety,
called in antibiotic,
but we had to drive another
hour and a half north,
now in the dark, to Carmel,
Past?
We had to drive all the way to Carmel,
in order to find the nearest-
Pharmacist,
Rite Aid, CVS, whatever it was.
Yeah.
So she goes up there,
and she gets her anti-diarrheal stuff,
and she gets her prescription medications,
and I'm plopping down a couple of enemas.
I'm like, we've got
opposite problems here.
Good Lord.
The cold brew doesn't clean me out,
when I travel, I can't get anything going.
So we're like bookends
on a sad bookshelf here.
This is our first night.
This is, just so you know, I mean,
this is probably how every
vacation is going to start,
20 years from now,
but this, you're just
getting an early start to it.
I bought four of those enemas,
and I'm just going to have
to carry them with me,
like a gunslinger, from now on,
I got to get holsters for these things,
every time I travel.
Oh.
I mean, you say that I'm worried-
What about the fiber?
routine oriented.
It doesn't help?
Like, my smoothie in the morning,
I don't take my smoothie stuff,
when I went on vacation,
I'm going to eat the breakfast
burritos and whatnot.
You know what?
I actually thought about this recently.
I think it's, it's legitimately good to,
If you eat the same thing
every single morning,
to take a break from it, on vacation.
Don't try to-
I kinda thought that too.
Don't try to bring your
smoothie situation.
First of all,
bringing your smoothie
situation on vacation,
would be annoying to
everyone who was with you.
But also I think-
There's only one person.
Legitimate, well, your
wife would be very annoyed,
but legitimately,
I think you should take a break,
from the same ingredients
over and over again,
every single day.
It can it give, be a little
bit of shock to the system,
but I think it is a good practice.
Yeah. It's not,
it's nothing that shoving a
needle nosed squish bottle
up your rectum.
Yeah, enema it out.
And squeezing, won't fix.
Yeah.
I'm sorry this is such a
visceral start to the episode.
Yeah.
I don't think it's going to get better,
but it is gonna get sexier.
I could talk about glitter boobs.
Yeah. We could-
Seen a lot of those,
in my day.
We could go back there.
It does get better,
but first let's promote some stuff.
Okay. All right.
You got a nice looking shirt.
Yeah. You know about our new venture.
It's called Sike!
Sike!
Again, this is something that we're doing,
but it's not a typical
mythical Rhett and Link thing.
It's something that the company is doing,
that kind of lives on its own.
It's the, what is it?
Now You see it, now you don't?
Make you look. That's what the slogan is.
Made you look.
You know, like back in the day, Sike!,
every single thing sold
on the Sike! Website,
is got a little bit of some
little curve ball going.
Case in point, tell them about this,
while I hold it in front of my face.
That is the mushroom pizza shirt,
and the reason it looks, it's
actually mushroom pizzas,
because if you go outside,
and the sunlight hits that bad boy,
it will turn into a pristine slice
of mushroom pizza.
Mushroom pizza!
But it's just mushrooms, if it's inside.
And of course,
this is just the,
one of the Sike! Shirts,
that I had never seen anything like this,
we got horizontal stripes and
then we got vertical stripes.
There's lots of things over there.
Go to sike.la
Sike.la,
Sike, S-I-K-E, dot L-A.
It's cool.
It's fun.
It'll surprise you.
And the people that look at you.
Made you look.
We got the stuff in her system,
and we got the stuff out of my system.
Wow. You guys just need to get together.
But it was like, you know what?
Tonight's just a wash.
Let's forget it.
And hopefully we did wash.
We did wash,
and we just started, you know,
start over with a clean
slate, in the morning.
We woke up, both feeling better.
Her issues were behind her.
Now you're trying.
And it started raining
Ey.
A lot.
Ooh.
It wasn't, it wasn't like
a hurricane or anything-
But there was like,
But it was a lot rain.
The most rain, in a
shortest period of time,
that Northern California has ever seen.
Well, yeah, in the Central coast, it was,
they called it like a bomb storm.
Like the word bomb was part of it.
Yeah. I can't remember what it was,
but yeah, it was nuts.
And so we got out,
we got some coffee, across the
street, with our umbrellas,
we come back to the room,
and it's, I mean, we got this nice cabin.
We got nothing to do, but each other.
Hm.
And so it was actually,
it was actually perfect.
We were, I mean, that's what we did,
each other.
And with nowhere else to go,
with nowhere else to be.
I mean, a lot of times
when you go on a vacation,
you know, there's things you want to do,
there's things you want
to tick off the checklist.
There's people that you're
going to hang out with,
that maybe you're traveling with,
like your brother and sister-in-law.
Yeah.
Like without any of that
and with no kids around,
it was like a glorious
focus on just the two of us.
And it was-
Better than a puzzle, for sure.
And let me tell you,
the rain made it an amazing experience.
Did you go outside?
The Judds have a song,
"Rockin' to the rhythm of the rain",
Oh yeah. The Judds.
That's a good song.
The Judds will get me going anytime.
We didn't play The Judds,
but I did think about it,
as we were rocking to
the rhythm of the rain.
We didn't go outside, to-
Make love in the rain?
To make love in the rain.
We stayed in this amazing cabin.
And then we were like, you know what?
Let's just lay here
and listen to the rain.
I was playing some music
at a certain point,
that was like, ambient sounds,
that complimented the rain,
but I just killed that noise.
Yeah. I mean, you know, if you,
if you tell your smart speaker,
or your sleep device or
whatever, to play rain sounds-
Yep.
This is a legitimate, top tier way,
to relax and go to sleep.
Oh yeah.
It's manufactured,
and it comes out of your smart speakers.
Right.
I think for the first time in my life,
I experienced it in
its most pristine form.
The night before-
You've never heard the rain on the roof?
Well, the night before we noticed,
that we weren't in a Redwood
grove, where we were,
we were in an actually an Oak Grove,
and acorns would fall and
hit the roof of our cabin,
and scare the shit out of us,
because of the problems we
were having, that first night.
Because it was just so loud.
Mm.
And it was,
I thought someone was knocking on the,
well, somebody was walking on the roof.
One foot at a time.
But then when you add,
when you replace that with rain,
it was a literal sound bath.
And it was an amazing
experience, just to lay there,
and it was so meditative.
I mean,
to have that thing that you can pull up,
on a YouTube video,
so that you can study or fall asleep,
to experience that in
its most natural form.
I, yeah,
I had never experienced a legitimate rain-
On a hot tin roof?
serenade.
It was, I mean, it was a, it
was a highlight of my life.
Especially sexing, in the rain, man.
That was amazing.
I know how you tend to get enthusiastic,
about things like this.
'Cause I make a decision,
to drink in life, in
those moments and say,
"You know what?
It doesn't get any better than this,
other things are going to be",
And this is me talking,
Wait no, that's what I'm
saying, that's what I'm saying.
I'm trying to figure out-
"It doesn't get any better than this.
Things have gotten this good,
but nothing is going to
get better than this."
You make a decision to do it,
but you also make a decision
to say that you're doing it,
and to try to get everybody
else to do it too.
So I'm just saying, was
Christy, like, "Yeah, I'm"-
Oh, she was, she was with-
Or was she shaking her head at you.
She was with me.
I mean, it was really magical.
I think she, you know, she's
taken up the reins too.
I mean, no one wants to be like,
"Hey, listen, you need to just, I get it.
This is awesome,
but I don't need you to
tell me that it's awesome."
I do understand that.
And I wasn't doing it forever.
I mean, we literally just laid there.
And listened to the rain.
For how long.
I don't want to ever forget it.
Definitely over an hour.
And this is after many hours
of intense love making.
Oh man, give me a break.
No, it wasn't many hours, but it,
when you don't have anything
else to do, besides each other,
you can stretch everything out.
And it's nice to get
reacquainted with that,
and say, "Hey, Remember on our honeymoon,
when we did it so much that we could,
we were walking like Cowboys?"
"Let's see if we can match that."
Yeah.
Let's see if we can
have multiple check-ins.
Yeah.
But you find yourself saying,
"Hey, let's actually,
you know what? Let's just
listen to the rain for an hour."
It might take me that long to, to re up.
Well, after that first
session, perspective changes.
The rain cleared up by mid afternoon,
and we went back to the place,
that you guys had recommended,
that we had been before,
called Nepenthe, or,
it's right on the coast.
Yeah.
It's like, there's a
bookstore and a restaurant.
And you sit on the back of the restaurant,
and you over,
Beautiful view.
You just look at the view,
Look at the ocean.
It's absolutely amazing.
We saw an amazing sunset.
And we were like talking to the waiter,
like making friends,
laughing louder than anybody else there.
You know?
Again, like I said, last
episode, it's just like,
just feeling in the zone, feeling like,
"Oh, look, we're having the
most fun. We're connecting."
We're like, "It feels like
we're on our honeymoon again."
And we're watching this beautiful sunset,
and I look over at Christy's purse,
and it had been up on the,
we were sitting at a bar,
so we could both sit shoulder to shoulder,
and watch the sunset,
like that was the best seat in the house.
And up on that bar,
her bag was open,
and it turns out something
was spilling out of it.
And every time that anyone walked by,
or the person sitting
right beside Christy,
on the other side,
could definitely see
that she had a huge box of
antidiarrheal medication,
just out there, in front of everybody.
And Christy's putting it away,
after, at the end of our whole meal,
after being there for like two hours.
And we're talking to the guy about it,
and he's like,
"Yeah, I saw that, but I
didn't want to say anything."
So it's, even though I don't know,
it just wouldn't leave us.
Like it was just,
the diarrhea was a specter.
Well, yeah, you need to be ready.
There were, we ate at that, we had a,
just a coffee at that place.
It's a cool spot, man.
And it's a very wild bird,
that was very aggressively
eating people's food-
Oh, there wasn't one of those.
Off of their table.
They must have shot him.
Must have killed him.
I might have been eating him.
I ate a chicken sandwich.
Yeah.
Next day,
we got up and there was
no rain in the forecast,
for that day.
So I'm like, all right,
today's the day that we're
going to go down by the river.
And again, no hiking.
We're going to go in full
meditative retreat mode.
They take these Adirondack
chairs, are you familiar?
Yeah, I believe so.
Well, describe it.
Adirondack chair, to me, is one of those,
it's high backed, made out of wood.
Yeah.
You just kind of leans back a little bit.
And you're kind of low to the ground.
Uh-huh.
They had taken pairs of those,
and put them in the Big Sur river,
because the river is basically
just a really wide stream.
And there's lots of places
where you can just sit on the rocks.
So we just went down
there and sat for a while,
and did nothing.
Feet in the water?
Too cold for that.
I was like, I'm going to
get totally ready for this.
I'm gonna put on my new sweatshirt.
I don't know if you noticed
This, this, this is the moment.
This is the moment where
you explain your sweatshirt.
I ordered this thing off an Instagram ad,
shout out to my friend, Todd Snyder,
teaming up with LLB.
It makes quite a statement.
I'm like, I think this is,
how do you say, ironic?
But not really.
It kind of says, I
don't really go camping,
but I like the idea of camping.
Yes.
And this isn't, I think this is Maine.
You know, you got some ducks flying.
You got some fall foliage,
going all the way down
the sleeves on this thing.
Yeah. It's quite a print.
That's not easy to do.
I did get a compliment or two for it.
Hmm.
What were the, what did they say?
Nice sweatshirt?
I think it was something like,
what did he say?
We were in one of these like little,
you'll find a little bookstore,
They got a lot of little-
on the edge of the...
With some like philosophical stuff.
People doing a lot of
introspection up in that place.
Yeah.
I think he said something
like, "That Sweatshirt is hot",
not hot, maybe he was like-
Mm. Fire.
I don't think he said, no cap.
I can't remember.
Who was this guy?
He was just a dude who seemed cool.
How old?
He was a little younger than me.
Huh.
So?
Okay.
I think it, it worked for him.
It definitely worked for me,
and I got the photos to prove it.
So here I am sitting in the Big Sur river,
in an Adirondack chair,
wearing my turtle neck sweatshirt.
Where were the feet?
The main scene.
They were on the rocks.
It was just too,
it was a little too cold.
But okay.
Put your feet in the water.
It's not in the water,
it's like on a rock, in the river.
Right, right, right.
Okay. Right.
So it's just another day of nothing.
And kind of looking-
It's good to have those.
Walking around the grounds of this place.
Going back to the room,
having another love making session,
it's just, you know,
it's just like you set
your parameters small,
and then it's just a
lot of, you know what?
I'm going to be naked.
I'm gonna be naked.
Like literally, there's
something in my throat.
It's gonna make me cry.
I was like, I'm going to
be naked in this cabin.
Oh yeah.
For a long time.
There's something about Big
Sur that does that to you,
because-
I loved it.
When we were up there,
we had, in the tree
house, we had the fire,
and then I was just like,
why do, clothes?
Why?
Yes.
And that's why,
There's a lot of naked.
when you're talking about
glitter boobs and stuff,
I'm actually, I was much
more open to that story.
And like putting a tube
sock on my, on my package.
It's one thing to be in a cabin,
another thing to be on
Duvall Street, in Key West.
I know, but it may be,
it's a slippery slope?
Not for me,
my feet are firmly
gripping the ground there.
I love being naked.
And I realized that
there's a freedom in that.
Something we were watching,
that I'll talk to you about,
kind of informed this mindset.
So again, I'll get to that.
But the experience was,
you know what, "This is my body.
These are our bodies,
we're into each other and
we're not into clothes."
Who needs 'em?
And we brought our own blanket,
'cause we brought our favorite blanket.
Hm.
So I mean, a little blanket is nice,
but there's just something
magical about being together,
and just saying, "You know what?
We need not, clothing."
Hm.
It just felt edifying.
It felt like, okay, I'm comfortable,
I'm accepted. We know each other.
We can, we can do this.
'Cause it's not the type of
thing that you normally do.
I mean, I don't walk
around my house naked.
Well, no, I mean, you got children.
Right.
But I do anticipate,
now, first of all,
I definitely do too.
I, I, well,
I do walk around my house naked.
If I am naked and I need to
get something from downstairs,
there are, and I'm like,
I don't want to put on anything.
I'm going to go down and get,
I got two boys and it's just,
but it isn't a regular thing,
but I do anticipate,
when the kids move out,
that it will become a normal thing.
I like that idea for me,
in my house.
And why not?
And then there's the pool,
I mean, I'll jump into that pool naked,
at the right time.
Yeah.
If the right people aren't
looking out the windows,
or the neighbors aren't home or something,
There's a couple of vantage
points from other yards,
I think, my pool,
It was everything I hoped it would be.
It's not that there's that much to report.
It's just, and I think that's the point,
is that I had this idea and again,
I'll have ideas of how
I want things to go.
and it started off really rough,
and I didn't let it get to me.
And even in day two,
when like things cleared up,
and I'm wearing the sweatshirt,
and we're out in the river,
or we're back, just
being in our nakedness.
Did everything go exactly how
I had written in the novel,
in my mind?
Of course not.
And Christy knows this about me.
And so there's certain points,
where she can see the
eyebrows crinkle a little bit,
or she can hear a little
intonation in something I'm saying,
and she can graciously redirect me,
to let go of my expectations,
and enjoy what we have
and what we're doing,
so that happened,
at a couple of points,
but overall,
it was just such a beautiful experience,
of us just being together,
with very little agenda,
and very little clothes.
Did you,
something I noticed,
that is unusual and like,
I noted it and Jessie noted it,
was how quickly I adjusted to vacation,
which is not an easy thing for me to do.
Now, we worked, you know,
we don't typically travel in October,
unless it's for work.
And so putting something
in the middle of October,
the way that the year is stacked.
It doesn't mean our busiest time.
And what happens when we travel is,
it isn't like anything we do less.
It's just we do more,
and it gets pushed on
either side of the trip.
And it's just the schedule
gets really packed,
on each side of the trip.
And we were working,
when I got home on the Wednesday night,
before leaving on a Thursday morning,
I was so worn out.
And there's so many things
kind of going on in my mind,
and things that I could
latch onto and worry about,
at any given time.
Yeah.
But something like, when
I got off the plane,
I kind of made this decision.
I was like,
I'm not going to worry
about anything work-related,
I'm not gonna think about the
stuff that I could be doing.
And also, I'm not going to obsess
about all the seven different things,
that I could see in Key West.
I've got these people
here, who know the place,
they've made reservations.
I'm just going to be along for the ride,
and actually had one of the
better times that I've ever had,
because I-
Wasn't in charge.
Well, I wasn't in charge,
but also it was like,
there's certain things that I didn't see.
I didn't go into Ernest Hemingway's house,
which I could have done, right?
As an example is like,
some everybody says, "Take the tour".
We didn't go.
And then I was like,
"Hey, leave something to
do the next time you come,
whatever don't, who cares."
It's very hard for me to be in the moment.
And for some reason,
because we were working so hard
right up until that moment,
I found myself being able to do that,
more than I ever have.
And I was like, man, am I
reaching an age where I can do it?
Is that what's happening?
It's crazy.
I was thinking the same thing.
On our drive back the next day,
I told Christy, I was like,
"You know what, for the past two days,
I don't think I thought about work."
And it was,
I mean, we had internet in the room,
when you're walking around,
and outside of your cabin,
we didn't have any service, so that helps.
But yeah, I mean, it felt like one of the,
'cause usually, you go
for a week long vacation,
and it takes half the time
to get to the point
where you're no longer
thinking about the stuff.
And then, as you're starting,
as it creeps back, to
when you're coming back,
into the real world, you
start thinking about it again,
You start thinking about the fact,
that the vacation is over.
Right.
"Oh, man, we're going
to go home on Tuesday.
There might be one day of a sweet spot,
in the middle, where you
didn't think of anything.
But yeah, I actually noticed,
I haven't thought about
work the past two days.
I gave myself permission to do that.
And I think I needed it
enough, and, you know,
I wanted to provide focus
on the right things.
And it was just,
yeah, it's kind of what
you want a vacation to be,
even though it was only
two full days for us,
and a travel day on either side,
that even being in the car was nice,
you know, 'cause it's such a
scenic drive and everything.
So yeah. I mean,
I definitely think that was my takeaway,
is that with this particular trip,
you got the beauty of the
ocean, the cliffs, the Redwoods,
and it just brings,
I would put it on that, for me,
that it brought me into
this meditative state,
and apparently, a good Floridian island
will do the same thing,
if you're in the right circumstances.
It's nice that we're
both, had that experience.
It may be,
It could just be, we
haven't traveled in a while.
Yeah.
'Cause I just, I noted it,
and I was like, "Man, I adjusted quickly.
How do I make sure I do this next time?"
I know, for real.
I mean, it's not easy, but.
There's one house that has like,
it's called a bridge house.
You have to walk across
the suspension bridge,
across the Big Sur river.
And then there's,
it has two bedrooms,
and then a kitchen,
and a nice living room area.
There's a barrel sauna outside,
right next to the river,
with a picnic table and bocci-ball,
and like these amazing rings-
You get in the sauna?
I didn't rent that.
Oh.
This is the place I want us to go back to.
Uh, oh.
And then if we bring other
friends, there's like,
they created these standalone bedrooms,
that are super nice, that you could,
you bring some other people,
it's like, I definitely
want to go back and do that.
In October,
that's the perfect time.
You get that rain,
but then it goes away,
and there's not all the fog coming off of-
We got lucky, we went in June.
Not a lot of fog.
Which is usually super
foggy and we got lucky.
But the thing that Christy and I watched,
in our downtime,
when we just couldn't go
at each other anymore,
was this Goop series on Netflix,
called Sex, Love and Goop.
I've seen the trailer.
Of course Goop is the Gwyneth Paltrow,
it's not just wellness.
It's all types of stuff.
It's just Gwyneth stuff.
Years ago, she got flack for like saying,
"Oh, put this egg in your
vagina for a long time."
Jade egg.
The Jade egg.
She named her dog after it.
She got a lot of pushback
for stuff like that.
And she did a mini series,
a Goop series on Netflix, like a year ago.
That was a bunch of,
"You spend a lot of money on something
that's very questionable."
It seems like that's
kind of the reputation
with what she's putting
out into the world.
But this new series,
she's not really the center of it.
And we watched the whole
thing while we were there.
And that's my recommendation,
but I wanted to talk through
some of this stuff with you,
because-
Uh-oh.
It's basically,
episodic, docu-series on sexual healing,
of real life couples,
paired with a sexologist.
Is that a sex therapist?
I would've called him a
sex therapist, but they're-
Sexologist more science-y.
Sexologist.
Wanted to jump in here
and give a clarification.
This is,
after recording everything
that you're currently listening to,
we had a discussion about Goop,
in light of the fact that,
a lot of current
controversy came to light,
after we recorded me, talking
about that Goop series,
and the controversy,
I mean, controversy is
nothing new to Goop,
but I just wanted to say,
there's certain therapeutic practices,
that are platformed in the series,
that people are pointing out
are illegal in most states,
highly questionable.
The one that I know about specifically,
is not one that I'm telling
you about, in this episode,
Right.
but in general,
I just wanted to say,
I'm not endorsing any of these practices.
I don't know enough to do that.
And I hope you know enough
to use your own judgment.
I'm basically just saying,
this was a fascinating show
to watch and be exposed to.
And it just got me
thinking about some things,
that I'm not saying are entirely right,
or even entirely legal,
because I don't know.
So I'm just putting that out there,
and framing this whole
conversation with caution,
that you need to be
responsible for yourself,
and how you apply any of
the stuff from that series,
if at all, no endorsements.
And I'll add that,
if you didn't already know,
Goop is not, it doesn't
necessarily have the reputation,
for being the most reliable,
or evidence-based source of
lifestyle and health advice.
You know, there's a number of things,
that have come up in the past few years,
but we are entertained by the way-
Yes.
that they go about things.
So again, whatever Link said,
I agree with, this is not an endorsement.
We were entertained by this thing,
but because of this recent controversy-
Whatever I said?
You weren't listening to what I said?
No.
Okay.
He agrees with what I said.
We just want to make sure that,
He endorses my non-endorsement of Goop.
We know how the internet is.
And we know that when
you talk about something,
that's controversial,
people assume that as an endorsement,
and we wanted-
It's not.
To confirm that it is not an endorsement.
Now let's go back to it.
And so the, these are
real people who like,
from all walks of life,
you got old people,
you got a lesbian couple,
you got people dealing with
challenges in being intimate,
or being, there being a mismatch,
in what drives them.
So it's kinda like seeing
the therapeutic techniques-
Mm-hm.
that they're experiencing, firsthand.
And sometimes with
multiple hands involved-
Ooh?
as I'll get to.
It gets wild and really out there,
in a couple of key places,
one that I'll tell you about,
but I really enjoyed the
heart behind this thing.
I mean, Christy recommended it,
and said, "Hey, let's watch this thing."
And I thought, okay, this will be fun.
This might make us horny.
That's what I was thinking.
But then it was actually very
eye opening and educational.
Some people might describe
parts of it as pornographic,
and it might make you uncomfortable.
But if you've been through Sex-tember,
I think you're probably be
ready to check this thing out.
But I give it to these couples,
who are like totally normal people,
with normal problems
in their relationships,
and they're like super vulnerable,
and the stuff that they
were asked to do, on camera.
But one of the things
that one of these
sexologists talked about,
was an erotic blueprint test,
that determines the way in
which you best receive pleasure.
And this is something that like,
I was able to connect
a few dots with this,
Is this a love language for sex?
Yeah. So the different
erotic blueprints are,
energetic,
sensual, sexual,
kinky or shape shifter.
So energetic
means you're aroused by
anticipation and yearning.
So it's like, it's not what is happening,
it's what's about to happen-
Foreplay.
Am I ready for this?
And it's,
it's foreplay,
but then sometimes,
it goes into more of this
like woo energy thing,
which I'll talk about.
Second one is sensual.
So you're turned on, when
all the senses are ignited.
However many there are five or six?
Like the vagina scented candle.
Yeah.
Sight, smell, touch.
What are the other ones?
Rubbing?
Insertion.
Sound.
Sounds, tastes.
The next one is sexual,
which is excited by nudity,
and/or other traditional
sexual characteristics.
A lot of this is associated
with the sexy bits, you know?
Okay.
The parts that you're
supposed to cover up on-
Like the ankles.
to be decent.
Angles?
Ankles,
I'm really into ankles.
No, I'm talking about
the twigs, the berries.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The tunnel of love,
The nappy dugout-
Mm, yeah.
as Ice Cube called it, in something.
So, and that's the one that
you tend to think about,
like, okay, when sexual stuff is,
is at play, when you're
activated sexually,
Yep.
but only that stuff.
Kinky.
Aroused by taboo.
Mm-hm.
And then shape shifter
is just all of the above.
So Christy, I mean, it doesn't,
it's not a teaching series.
It's more like they're sharing this,
with the people in order,
so that this one particular
couple could understand,
how did, kind of like
a love language thing?
How do they like meet
each other's expectations?
And like, she's putting
one of them on a table,
and then it's like,
"Okay, based on your
survey, you're kinky."
And she's like, "Oh, I am."
And then he like, gets out.
She gives the sexologist,
gives her partner a paddle.
And he like-
And he's like, I'm not kinky.
I'm just a high school principal.
He was, I mean, his eyebrows
are going up all the time,
as he's like trying to figure out
how hard does she like to
be spanked with this paddle.
Right.
And then there's like
the whips and the thing,
like the big thing with
the chains hanging from it.
And it's like, well, you don't
whip the person with this.
You just slowly drape it on them.
And draping on her crotch.
And then you have the
weight of these chains.
Just the feeling of chains.
I think she was sensual and kinky,
if I remember correctly.
But then they switch up and
they put him on the table,
Oh I'm a golfer.
And he wasn't, he wasn't like that.
I mean, they gave him Wolverine claws-
Holy.
to start scratching
down her body,
and like a very, no blood was drawn.
Right, yeah.
It was very approachable.
It made kinky approachable.
You're a big Wolverine fan.
It did make me think that
I was a shape shifter,
because no matter what I saw-
Whay,
I wanted to try that.
I could try that.
That feels like the page
I'm on so far, yeah.
They put him on the table and,
and then the sexologist is
like, "You are an energetic."
And then he started talking about,
put your hands over the person.
"Do you feel the energy?"
And I'm like, "Okay, here we go.
I don't believe any of this shit."
But then they started,
he started being touched,
in a way that,
the dude had what is
called an energetic orgasm.
He came in his pants
without being touched?
He had a,
I don't know if he
ejaculated in his britches,
Well, that's an orgasm.
But his whole body was shaking.
He was like, he started crying.
It was wild.
It really was.
And I didn't know, this was a thing.
And then they're like,
"Okay, yeah, this is what
you are. And this is-"
What happened though?
Just hand placement, without touching?
Honestly,
I can't remember all the
specifics of what they did to him.
Maybe it was because-
Nothing was vibrating?
Like under the table,
that we couldn't see?
Nothing that I saw,
you'll have to watch it for yourself.
If you want to really,
I can't remember the
specifics of what they did.
It was more about the result,
and him knowing that this was kind of,
this was his sexual, his,
his sexual love language,
his erotic blueprint.
But then the sexologist
is like, now you get off.
Now, let me show you where you
can go with this, basically.
Since this is a way that
you're able to get off,
and you guys can learn
that from each other.
Go stand next to a transformer?
No, just sit here and watch me.
And then the sexologist
lays down on the table,
fully clothed.
Uh-oh.
And she's like,
I'd like to introduce you to
my business and life partner.
This middle-aged bald dude comes out,
and he looks like a,
I mean, he's got a golf shirt on.
I don't remember what he had on-
What was his name?
but I remember that,
I don't remember, like Raymond,
or something like that.
but he looked like a,
like an evil bond villain.
He had a, I wouldn't say
that his head was bulbous,
but it was bald.
And all of his facial features,
were kind of concentrated on
the lower half of his face.
It's better that way.
So it's kinda, it was kind of like-
That way, you can see
smell and taste things,
that are all at the same time.
And he had a smirk, but
he didn't really talk.
And then all of a sudden,
he starts putting his
hands over his partner,
and he never, ever touched her.
Just like David Copperfield.
It was kind of like this
supervillain magician type thing.
And he had one hand,
it was kind of, you know,
when in Lord of the Rings,
when Sauron put his
hand over the palantir,
And his hand was like,
it was kinda like he was drawing
a connection with Sauron,
out of that crystal ball,
and his fingernails and his
hand was getting twiggy.
It was just weird.
That happened on Netflix?
Like this dude,
what he did was, he did that,
with his hand above her head.
And then-
She got her eyes closed?
Kind of over her crotch-
Uh- oh. Oh dear.
And he looked like he
was pulling on strings,
like a freaking puppeteer.
And then she is just going crazy.
Like she is,
she is undulating having
a full body orgasm,
all over this table.
All over the table?
Like she was writhing all over the table,
moaning and arching her back,
and putting her knees in the air,
and throwing her legs all over the place.
Good Lord.
And he was never touching her,
but doing this thing that,
from my perspective,
it was an elaborate performance.
Well, can I?
And I think-
Having not seen it.
It was wild.
I didn't really buy it,
but the other guy totally bought it.
Well, here's the thing.
You ever,
you know, like, this hasn't
happened to me recently,
but I've done it with my
kids, where you're like,
You're doing it with your kids?
You know, you're tickling your kids,
and then you're, you've got them,
you've got them held down,
and then you get really
close to tickle them,
and they laugh-
Yes.
because it's the anticipation
of getting tickled.
Like I think that-
They would call that
an energetic response.
I think that it is, I mean, listen,
I don't know.
I don't claim to know things,
about metaphysical things anymore.
That's kind of where I'm at,
but the idea that he,
there's literally like some energy field,
that he's kind of running
through her vagina,
and then coming out the top of her head,
And literally, like, what
was the guy in Pinocchio?
Gepetto.
He's Gepettoing his woman.
I don't think that's what's happening,
but the idea is so powerful-
Right.
In that her mind,
is literally able to
activate a sexual response.
Like I totally believe
that that could happen.
I agree with that.
And there was no denying that this guy,
who was in tears,
and took him hours, to recover,
from what happened to him on the table,
it just seemed like it was a
very extreme demonstration,
that might, I don't know,
the waters got kinda muddied for me.
And you expect a little bit
of that from a Goop thing.
Yeah. It's got to be a little Goopy.
You gotta get Goopy.
There was a couple of
other Goopy moments too,
that those are great reasons to watch,
and just like,
just for your jaw to drop.
But again,
I have to recommend it,
because the way that these
couples were so vulnerable,
and the sexual component
to their relationship,
and one of the things
that clicked early on,
was they said,
one of the sex-perts said that,
you know, lovemaking is, is a skill.
It's like a craft.
And it was really cool too,
for us to be watching it.
And then to have all of this time,
where it's like, okay, we can,
we don't have anywhere to be,
or anything else to do.
Just raining.
And so we can like actually embrace this,
as something that, there's
still a lot to learn
about our own bodies,
and about each other's bodies.
I'd never heard of these
classifications, you know,
had you?
Energetic, sensual, sexual,
kinky, shape shifter?
No, not broken down like that.
Right, and knowing that
there might be a mismatch,
to like the woman, in
that couple was like,
"Am I going to have an orgasm
at any point in my life?"
Am I going to, she said,
"Am I going to have an
orgasm before I have a baby?"
'Cause I think they were,
they were thinking about
trying to have kids,
but she kind of wanted to
check that box, you know?
as she should.
But I was blown away by that,
just the vulnerability.
And just how,
because I haven't read
a lot of those books,
which I'm sure you could
get some of this stuff from,
it was, it was a cool introduction to it.
And it has some sensational
parts that really popped,
that made it a lot of fun to watch.
We're going to bring a sexologist in,
for sex-tember 2022?
Maybe.
Right.
I mean, I'll lay down-
I couldn't fit on this table right here.
I mean, would you lay down-
Have to bring in a different table.
For a Netflix-
My head would go
out that side and my feet
would be out this side.
I mean, a lot of these people,
they will be like,
I'm going to do this on Netflix.
Like they would say that,
as part of it.
Well they're getting paid,
I mean, probably a pretty
significant significant amount.
It was very cool though.
What I will say, it's interesting.
We had very different trips,
but there are parallels,
even in this area.
And I think that this is, again,
this is typical of vacations for,
for me and Jessie and you and
Christy, as you've described.
But, I actually wasn't with Jessie,
the entire week leading up.
'Cause she went to North Carolina,
at the beginning of the week,
and was kind of hanging
out with her family there,
and then went down to
the Keys on Wednesday.
So I'm flying down on Thursday night,
so we haven't seen each
other for like four days.
Oh, that's a good technique.
Send her early.
Well, she sent herself,
had some business to take care of,
in North Carolina.
And you know,
I got in at 6:30,
so she is,
they're all ready to go
out, for dinner, right?
And so, Chris picks picks
me up, but Jessie's there.
And she steps out of the car,
and she's in her little black dress,
and all made up in her heels.
She didn't drive up on a bike.
No, she did not.
And I'm like, "Okay, well
what time is dinner?"
You know what I'm saying?
Because if we got, we
have a little bit of time,
let's go to the hotel room.
And I mean, it was very intense-
I like that idea, meet on the vacation.
I'm not saying we had sex at the airport.
I'm saying we waited till we
got back to the hotel room.
And then there's always this thing,
kind of what you were getting at before,
which is just like
sometimes, in a relationship,
if there's like pre-dinner sex,
sometimes you you're less
motivated after dinner, right?
You're kind of like,
well, no, we followed up dinner,
and then proceeded to, I mean-
It was reset. You hit a reset button.
and then it was, it became a thing.
This is going to happen
multiple times a day,
the whole time that we're together.
And of course,
the whole dynamic that we
talked about, during sex-tember,
where you have to get
yourself into a place,
where you're willing to not
care about people hearing you,
and people in the room
next to you hearing you,
and that kind of thing.
But we got there very quickly,
and kind of maintained that.
And we didn't really talk,
we didn't talk about it.
I mean we talked about
how we were having a really great time,
and how we were really connecting,
and we enjoyed being with each other.
And, but yeah, it was a really,
we were very in sync,
much more than when we were kayaking.
I mean, I thought about
trying to slip off,
and have sex on the kayak,
considering how well things were going.
And maybe that would have, you
know, solved some problems,
but no, that didn't happen.
But yeah, it was a really good time,
for that kind of connection
probably, but maybe,
I mean, I haven't done
the puppeteer thing,
so maybe I got to watch this thing.
Yeah, that's what I'm telling you, man.
So that's my recommendation,
actually, for this one,
is the Goop, Sex Love and Goop.
And you know, I've told you
what you're signing up for,
so, if you're not into that,
you shouldn't watch it.
And it's like, yeah, you're going to,
there's some eye-rolly
parts to it, but it's like,
I'll just take it with a grain of salt.
You think you don't have
to agree with everything,
in order to get something out of it,
That's what I thought.
You know, that, that's one of the,
one of the things I most enjoy about
my post evangelical life.
Yeah.
As an evangelical Christian,
there was, for me,
there was always this,
I was very in a very
defensive and protective mode,
with every single thing that I enjoyed,
every single thing that I watched,
every single conversation that I was in,
you're kind of always on guard for,
is this an op, first of
all, you're with people,
is this an opportunity to witness to them?
But then when you're watching something,
you're trying to make sure
that it's going through the proper grid,
and you're classifying
people as, "This isn't good,
this is not Christ-like.
This is not a Christian.
This is not biblical."
You're either in or you're
out, so every, yeah,
everything was assessing that.
And there's an interesting
thing with what I don't-
Is it right or wrong?
Are you in, or you're out?
And that grid doesn't exist anymore.
Can I do that?
So now it's kind of like, huh. Okay.
But the interesting thing is,
it isn't like anything
goes and everything's good,
but it's kind of like,
I can watch something and
just take it in and be like,
this doesn't have to change
the way I feel about, think
about this, but it might,
you know, and again,
I don't believe the energy stuff.
I mean, it could be true,
but I don't know if
there's a way to prove it.
I haven't experienced it,
but being able to watch
something like that and be,
this is entertaining/informative,
maybe it'll spark something for us.
And I don't have to have this
complex, informed opinion,
about why it's worldly.
That's one of the best things
about my life, at this point.
It just makes, there's a
lot less emotional energy,
put in like putting things in boxes.
And I think that, you know,
since this is kinda like a,
a sex addendum to sex-tember,
you know, weeks later,
I do think there are ripple effects,
in me and Christy's
relationship from sex-tember.
It's really getting in that head space,
where you're thinking about it,
well you and I are thinking
about it and talking about it.
And then Christy and I are,
the four of us did, in that one episode.
And then,
she's grateful.
I think she's glad that
she was on the show,
because it's part,
it's one of the factors that led to us
having intentional intimacy,
and giving attention to our sex lives.
And saying, "Okay, that will
actually be part of the mission
for this trip for us."
I'm already looking back on sex-tember,
and being very, very grateful for it.
And I think Christy's reading a book,
called "Come As You Are",
which I would also recommend that book.
And so it's, you know,
the wave has crescendoed,
but it's still moving us along,
in terms of giving attention to it.
And also realizing that now
that we've talked about it,
it's, it's less and less weird,
every time we bring it up.
She's the one that's like,
and she put it in our text thread,
she's like, "Look at this Goop series,
I'm going to watch this.
You guys should watch this too."
You know, it's like,
I think she could have done that before,
but maybe she wouldn't have,
maybe she wouldn't have identified that.
I think we are realizing the benefits
of having those conversations,
and kind of bringing it to the surface.
Now, all that being said,
if I had to predict,
on the backside of our Big Sur trip,
is it now we're having so much more sex?
It's like, no, I can
already tell that it's like,
"Man, that was great."
And that was very concentrated.
And now we're getting
back to our normal lives,
and our normal rhythm,
and our normal,
frequency is the word I'm looking for,
you know,
of being intimate.
But again, because we talk
about it differently now.
We talk about it more often,
we talk about it even more openly.
And so I think it was a good thing.
I'm glad we did it.
I'm glad we're still doing it,
Keep doing it.
Hah.
I do think that that is,
you know, we talked about
this during sex-tember,
but yeah, I think it is worth repeating,
is just the idea that,
just like anything,
that communication and
talking about something,
leads to enhancements and progression,
in that particular area
of your relationship.
And that might be your
sexual relationship.
'Cause I do think there is
a, there's a tendency for it.
I mean, I'm not a very
routine oriented person,
but that doesn't really matter,
because there is a tendency,
you kind of get into things
that are comfortable,
and I'm talking about in
relationships in general, right?
Yeah.
If there's like,
"Okay, well, this thing
about you annoys me,
or I feel hurt in this way,
but I just don't know
how to talk about it.
I don't know how to bring it up."
And so years will pass,
and we don't really make, like,
we just accept that
this is the status quo.
And I don't know,
my impression is that there are,
there's many,
there's many couples in relationships,
where there's issues like that,
that relate to their sexual lives,
where it's like, "Hey, we looked up,
and 15 years had passed,
and we haven't had a
meaningful sexual connection."
Not because we don't want to,
but because there's something,
maybe it's we're on a different page,
when it comes to the stuff,
the way that it was
broken down or whatever.
And that's the thing that
I loved about that series,
is that these were not people
that were celebrating how
great their sex lives are.
It's like these are people
with real challenges,
and deeply rooted, in
certain case studies,
issues, that go to the core of
who they are as individuals,
and what they're bringing
to the relationship.
And they put all that out there.
And I think it's, you know,
I'm extremely grateful for the experiences
that Chris and I have.
And I know you are with you and Jessie,
like things are going so well.
And that was one of the concerns
that I had with sex-tember,
was like, I just feel like we celebrate
how much we have to be thankful for,
and that we can build on,
knowing that there's so many people who,
as you're getting at right now,
it's like they're in a different place,
because of different reasons,
that aren't their fault,
necessarily, or most likely.
And it takes work and sometimes
help to get through that.
And so I applaud those people,
and I think those are great examples,
to kind of round out
something that we're not able
to talk about, when it's-
Well, I mean, it's just the intention,
the decision to go on that show,
which who knows what the
casting process is or whatever,
but you know, you don't have
to go on a Netflix show,
but it might take,
"Hey, let's actually go see
a sex therapist, as a couple.
Oh, this is, this is uncomfortable-"
Yeah.
"But what about the next 10 years?"
It's anything,
when you need to talk to
somebody about anything,
that breaking through
that initial conversation,
again, it's just so much
easier to not have it.
It's just so much easier to just
have tomorrow be just like today.
Yeah. Back-burner it, or no burner it.
But I mean,
so when I was talking
about enjoying being naked,
and embracing that,
it was informed by messages in that show,
and just saying, you know what?
So I got to a point with Christy,
and I was like, I think I
want to start an Only Fans.
Okay. All right.
It's like, it can be both of us.
You can be in charge of the camera.
If you don't want to do it,
you can be in charge of the camera.
And my face doesn't have to be on it.
I don't know. I could
be in a, not, I want an,
I could do an anonymous thing.
I think I could be an exhibitionist.
Hmm. Okay.
And I doubt this is
going to actually happen.
So does she.
But there are couples, you know,
there's so much
independent porn right now.
And there are couples
that, for whatever reason,
because of whatever else they do,
or just their own prerogative,
they don't show their faces.
You know, you're going to have,
the tattoo could be a problem.
And you have your wife's name, as I do,
my wife's name, on our asses.
So you'd have to put something over that.
And then you've got the-
Yeah.
The Elvish tattoo,
that you have to do something with that.
A lot of bandaid.
And you can't say anything, you know,
you don't wanna make any noises.
I'd use an accent.
You can use a French accent.
You're good at that.
And I mean, it's a natural
extension of we do, right?
Emphasis on the extension.
No, I don't think I will ever do it.
I was messing with her, tongue in cheek,
but I don't know.
You got people,
you got people who are
legitimately going to think,
that you might start an Only Fans,
but that's a good place to have people.
Don't go searching,
I haven't perused Only Fans.
I don't know, you know
what the thumbnails show,
but don't peruse it on my account,
trying to find me, 'cause you won't,
and it'll be really easy,
'cause I'll be the guy
wearing this sweatshirt,
and nothing else.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well focus on the ducks.
Well, hopefully you learned a lot
this week and last week,
as we ended up just doing
sex-tember all over again.
#EarBiscuits. Tell us what
type of sexual type you are.
No dog, we don't want to know.
No, no, wait, listen.
Save it.
Because I mean,
I have every intention of
doing sex-tember again,
but I don't know how it's going to change.
We kind of already told the stories.
I think we might have to
just bring in some experts.
I don't know, man.
I don't know. It's too early
to say, but I, you know,
I'd really like to do it again.
I'll have learned a lot from
my Only Fans experience,
to discuss.
Yeah, right.
Talk at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.